the radio show LA Film Festival it would
be wonderful Deborah echoing right on
and right on online tell us what is
right on right I is a live writers
portrait and right on a line learn from
that so right on santa monica california
we need for a second wednesday of the
month at barnes and open Santa Monica
I'm trying to get a ton of people my
next meeting now but also right on our
mind being great on the support group
has been meaning in Santa Monica 48 than
half years and before then I had one
back when I lived in chicago two run
double in schaumburg so with me and
ridership workers have a very long
history in a way mike is different from
a lot of others isn't about goal setting
and productivity and never hey right on
online we website right at online.com
started it'll be two years in august
since i've had its own dedicated URL and
that's a place for writers in all areas
to get information about anything
because most writers write more than one
thing so my cover of fiction nonfiction
screenwriters radio talk show host you
know I I catch everything because all
right is right at least one thing in all
writers can support they need some way
to like yeh raat surely them and help
them move forward and so website has
author interviews twice a week x 4
columns video interviews and then right
on wednesday which is events and things
coming up that are writers should know
about and aren't just in LA but all over
the country we have some members in
other parts of the world so you know
maybe i'll start getting events from our
members and norway and india and
wherever else tarzana so sure about so
you have a group that's like a self-help
type therapy setting
in European whatables most people back
most writer spot is it that voice of the
naysayer that they've had throughout
their life they can't do something
there's a more self-imposed this is
their own dinner team in them well I
think but what holds most riders back is
they need somebody who says you can do
it you put enough time and effort and
energy into something you know you can
you know get that film done write a blog
get whatever is in your heart out on the
page all you need is somebody saying
okay you could do it and then on the web
site you can post your goals either on
the facebook page or on right down on
line you can post remarkable and it's
just a place to say okay I'm going to do
this and then at the end of the week you
could say okay I did this in it's just
another way so other people can route
you want it you have some accountability
as well